rush to get out of town is already
underway triple-a says that more than 49
million Americans are expected to drive
at least 50 miles over the holiday Kris
Van Cleave joins us from the road in
Arlington Virginia where it looks like
traffic is moving okay at this hour Kris
what can we expect in terms of the
biggest traffic headaches around the
country
well good morning certainly tomorrow is
the day where you're going to see the
most Americans hitting the road for
Thanksgiving and for most Americans it
is a driving holiday the absolute worst
time to leave on your commute in almost
every major city in the u.s. is 4 p.m.
tomorrow
it stays particularly bad through about
7 o'clock tomorrow because you get
rush-hour Plus everybody trying to get
to Grandma's house now Google has looked
at traffic patterns around Thanksgiving
and has found there are some other
delays that could really slow you down
for example if you haven't finished your
grocery shopping yet do not go to the
grocery store between 5:00 and 6:00 p.m.
tomorrow night
because that's when everybody else who
hasn't finished their grocery shopping
goes to the grocery store it's also the
worst time to hit the liquor store now
if you're thinking about Black Friday
shopping we know some people start
really really early in the morning but
traffic peeks at the shopping mall
around 1:00 p.m. Friday and then folks
go to the movies traffic around movie
theaters hits its peak around 6:00 p.m.
Friday night now we're driving to Reagan
National Airport this morning because
coming up.we we know a lot of people are
flying and they're gonna be squeezing
into those airplane seats we're gonna
tell you about the controversy
surrounding the FAA s effort to
determine what where seats need to go
like what's the smallest safe size for a
seat and not everybody agrees Jericka
all right Kris Van Cleave for us thank
you